for how long was this an idea that you
had entertained directing your own
feature film oh not at all I mean if I
had entertainment idea of directing it
was such a subconscious urge it's kind
of like a you know a subterranean thing
that I'd pushed away and part of that
was you know the the privilege of having
all these fantastic and fun jobs and
working with all these great people in
other capacities it really never really
came up I mean imagine 25 almost 30
years in the business writing
screenplays and having the I I mean it
would never came up but it was like I'd
finished the script I go well maybe I
could direct it or I don't know you know
like Angley or somebody like like it
just was not any minute question but I
did get the you know look at a couple
years ago I had the kick in the rear end
of getting fired for my studio gig it
happens and we gonna do and a youngest
daughter who was off to college and I
thought I really just cannot be that guy
who's you know at twelve noon on his
laptop in bed unshaven pretending like
he's doing deals thing I thought wow
this is an opportunity and it was a real
privilege to be able to take it okay so
at what point during the writing or
revising of the indignation script did
you make the decision that you were also
going to direct it yeah I acquired it at
focus with the intention of writing it
for Aang and then partially my own fault
I got them very excited about things
like 3d I had just been working on a
film called Coraline and it was the
first 3d film that in the universal
studio and focus that had ever gone
through that process and and he picked
up that ball and ended up doing life of
pi all right and and and just got the
bug so by the time that I left focus
clearly this is not a film that could
sustain the kind of budget that a 3d and
now of course with hang high
rate 120 frames a second 4k expanded
dynamic range etc experience that he's
really pursuing right now to change the
future of cinema so I thought well
that's just leaves me left so what did
you have to do you have so many skill
sets already from all the other jobs
that you've had on film sets what did
you have to do to feel like you were
really ready to take on the director
role well that question assumes that
there was something I could do to make
myself feel ready which is a big
assumption no first of all of course you
just pretend to everybody around you and
that's the first step and and then three
things honestly you noted that one was I
was super honest with my crew and with
my cast that if you had a question for
me that I couldn't answer if there's
there was some you know something you
said to me I didn't understand I would
always admit it just always would and
I'd say and I'd ask questions and we get
through it but I said to them that and i
said here's the quid pro quo and here's
the guarantee i will always still answer
the question and make up make a decision
because i found in my in my experience
it's been three decades as a producer
studio head I've always said this is
becoming mantra I I said there are two
kinds of pardon my french two kinds of
[ __ ] directors [ __ ] and people
who can't make up their minds and I
always would prefer to work with type
number one you know just like that's my
preference so yeah I always I will
always make a decision what do you think
it is about Philip Roth that makes him
so ripe right now there's also a great
movie called American pastoral which is
coming out directed by Ewan McGregor
coming out later this year it's really
good both these films are fantastic why
were you drawn to him and why do you
think filmmakers are in general a good
question i guess i mean look there's a
meme that says he's really hard to adapt
well and that's been the kind of thing
why was i drawn to Philip Roth
answer that question honestly I would
have to probably expose my neuroses
anxiety Zab love I mean like I assume
there's certain Jewish men of a certain
age here who read port noise complaint
like way too early for our development
like it was like well we were so normal
and then like oh you know like port
noise can play I mean right okay Sonia
um we can bring a sofa thank you yeah
seriously did I know you're not getting
paid enough for that but you know I
honestly this book look this indignation
is his 29th novel and I came across it
at an airport it was a mass market
paperback you know and I didn't read it
because I thought wow Philip Roth books
they always make such great movies this
is gonna be amazing I read it because I
you know I'm a kind of fan I fell in
love with the characters I love them all
I love even the bad guys Dean Caudwell I
love this guy you know mom I'm sorry I
love her and and so when I ended it I
thought here's the here's the weird deal
about Philip Roth the genius of him I
mean I do think he's one of the greatest
writers who's ever written in English
certainly American English and he's very
much alive is the voice right this kind
of brutal honest relentlessly like just
clinically horrifically honest voice
that somehow at the end of it the
brutality of it leads you to a place of
empathy well guess what when you're
adapting a novel to cinema the first
thing you lose is voice there is no in
cinema we have a camera and it records
people you hire who are wearing costumes
and get haircuts and wear makeup and
they say stuff and they do things and
it's like immediate and we can pretend
we have voice through certain kind of
stylistic choices and I made some very
strong style as a choice here but that's
not a substitute that's not the modality
of the voice of an author but in this
book the characters I realized they
brought me like I could see it happening
with them and that's halfway and then
the next fifty percent of course is your
actors could you get that sold their
souls on screen so this is one of the
few Roth books i think has that
you definitely use a handful of theater
people Danny Burstein Linda Eamonn of
course Tracy Letts was that a conscious
decision to fill your cast with people
who have done that kind of work well
when you're making a movie for almost no
money in New York City and theater
people are really used to those wages
that's always a plus that's a that's a
help for sure I mean like we you know
this is the typical like when you go to
these q and A's and get you know the odd
you know indie film and we always sit up
here with like no money and so they were
so like a nobody believed in it think
but yeah look we shot it in 24 days
right so there were no trailers my
everybody's hanging out so I had the
benefit of the greatest actress in the
world who many people have never heard
of right and Linda Eamon nominated twice
for Tony and I mean she's just I mean
mom right yeah thank you and she's by
the way I love her but she is even more
intimidating in real life that she was
on screen like I mean scared the crap
out of me anyhow Tracy Letts of
obviously a Pulitzer Prize winner Tony
when Danny Burstein who's currently
Tevye on Broadway and as dad as dad and
you know he's been nominated six times
the Tony Award he's like the Susan Lucci
of the tony's is lost every time he just
lost this year to hamilton of course and
put your own right yeah yeah Oh tries to
chaperone thank you that's like one of
my favorite musicals ever like the
moment so we're just like nerdy guy but
even the boys Ben Rosenfield it plays
flesser the roommate is in love with
Marcus Phil ettinger the other roommate
can the poor Pico Alexandra who's sunny
the head of the Jewish fraternity and
Noah Robbins who plays poor Marty who
gets caught at the end every one of
these guys I know we complain about
Millennials and our kids and their work
ethic unbeliev they're all theater
actors who work their rear ends off and
they killed it we have to talk about
whether I think there's two real
centerpiece scenes there's the one with
Logan and Tracy that which was 14 pages
right in the script and then there's
that great scene with Logan and Linda at
the end which is to me like a just as
fantastic and I understand there was
spontaneous applause at
the Dean Caudwell seen amongst this
audience tonight which is great I mean
it was just a celebration of the joint
survival was like oh you're still here
oh god are those two scenes as
monumentous in the book or did you read
the book and think oh I really want to
do like a cool centerpiece long
two-hander seen here know what you know
it's honestly crazy because I'm supposed
to be all professional one just like
yeah I'm gonna check I went the first
draft of course when you're adapting
novels is a screenwriter at least my
technique I have a foolproof technique I
simply transcribed the dialogue from the
novel puts leg lines in and like type
the end and like prey it's a movie and
then two years later I'm like wow that
was not that did not work out but um but
um so I flipped through that scene I
knew it was a little longer I didn't pay
much attention and then I read the first
draft I was like oh you know that's long
but I'm a professional I can hone that
down I can you know little it into
something and then three drafts later it
was just still sitting there and I
realized I will never be able to raise
the money for this movie it's a 40-page
seen obviously American cinema industry
like at past three pages you get
arrested right so so it was very strange
i said okay if we do it we got to do it
and do it do it that way so yeah but i
didn't feel like it was a was only after
the script was done that i thought what
the hell are we gonna do yeah and how
many days did it take to shoot that one
how many minutes is the scene well
here's what I did I mean I I worked
really ugh and honestly worked on that
scene for six months Tracy came in
completely cuz of scheduling he only
could come in the day before but he was
a hundred percent off book we didn't
really rehearse it much I had very
specific architecture to the scene
because if you just cover it and then
edit it would just be a plump little you
know thing so not that you need to
notice this stuff but every from kind of
lenses to camera angles to who's in the
center frame you know from high angle to
low angle the whole scene has no
architecture so is that without it I
don't think we'd have survived and
they're very specific blocking and
believe me you know if you're a
first-time director and you're saying
see Ashley I think you need to stand up
on this line there but it's a weird
scene because I know it's about talking
and whatever it's a weirdly physical
scene there's weird inappropriate
touching kind of violative and it's all
timed it's all set so so yeah the date
of it I kind of quote forgot to tell the
actors that until the morning of that we
were not going to shoot the scene in
pieces that everything you saw on that
when the film was shot as part of 18
minute takes real again and again and
again and again we shot a terabyte of
data we shot the scene in one day
because we don't you know at that time
and only until the end at the very end
we did a we broke off because I couldn't
have Logan having a mouthful of mushroom
soup right in his mouth during the scene
because he was going to throw up but
that was it the rest of it was it was
all everything was part of an 18-minute
take let me just say I know you're very
busy teaching philosophy in producing 3d
boxing movies but please make another
movie because this was terrific we're
like many congratulate you so much and
thank you for coming thank you all for
staying around on a Sunday night have a
great night